premier conseil des ministres après un
an et demi de crise politique
un nouveau gouvernement qui sera à terme
composée de 36 ministre à sa tête
benyamin netanyahou leader du likoud et
benny ganz chef de chaos la vanne tous
deux ont conclu un accord de partage du
pouvoir pour trois ans le premier
ministre sortant a admis des concessions
la crise mondiale du coronavirus secoue
les continents et les pays et a fait des
centaines de milliers de victimes dans
le monde entier
nous avons vu l'épidémie nous avons vu
le danger et nous avons donc décidé
ensemble de mettre de côté nos
différences et de nous tenir côte à côte
contre les grands défis que l'épidémie
du coronavirus mais devant nous même son
de cloche du côté de benny gantz
l'ancien chef d'état major semble
d'ailleurs ne pas avoir eu d'autre
alternative que d' accepter ce compromis
nous avons eu trois scrutins en un an et
demi les gens ont parlé et nous ont
laissés nous les dirigeants des deux
camps avec deux choix
l'unité ou une sorte de guerre civile
les gens nous ont dit d'arrêter de nous
battre entre nous et de commencer à
travailler pour eux leur accord prévoit
un partage équitable des ministères il
va permettre à chaque camp de
redistribuer des postes à ses alliés
politiques
d'après les termes de cette entente
benyamin netanyahou reste donc premier
ministre pendant 18 mois
viendra ensuite le tour de benny gantz
pour une période équivalente mais ce
gouvernement hérite d'une économie mise
à mal notamment par la crise du
coronavirus il doit en plus se prononcer
sur un projet d'annexion de pans entiers
de la cisjordanie occupée
[Musique]